why tonight how are first of all how are
you oh I mean I can't even feel this
right now I'm so I'm so excited by what
just took place incredible how did you
guys pull this off I wanted to do it for
Christy no she was going through a lot
of pain and I feel like us rallying
behind this and making sure we delivered
would make her feel better and every
moment that I felt like giving up and I
felt like I couldn't do it and it was
hours and hours of rehearsal in these
past couple days and three days it's not
even coupled and I just think of my mom
and I'd call her we'd FaceTime her
something and she'd be sitting there in
bed with her cast on and I'm like she
can she can do that I can do this you
know like and also she was rehearsing
for three weeks and that's hard work and
I just wanted to show her now have the
rumors that you're all wearing the same
costumes that you just popped into mom's
costumes I fit her exact sizes that's
pretty wild
yeah have you heard from the producers
is there an open slot will you join us
again next year when you're all healed
up I have not heard from the producer in
the video when she's on the floor and
I'm behind her and she's like oh my god
I broke it 30 seconds later she's like
can I do it again next year yeah
literally we want there to be a spot for
you this is say there's here next year's
your year what was it like for you
hopping out of that car because in the
package we saw this was a tribute to
your mom this is your mom's song what
was it like to be you know her daughter
and then be holding her spot on Dancing
with the Stars to her iconic buck it was
surreal it was like definitely surreal
all the moments that I was sitting in
that car and I and I'm listening to the
whole package go over and
I'm hearing my mom's voice and my voice
and my terrified reactions and
everything I really just got out there
and I was like this is it let's do it
you know what was going through your
mind in that second we watched that
footage we ran it on Entertainment
Tonight
tonight and then they played it again
during the show in that moment what's
going through your mind you know you've
broken something you've seen your share
of injuries and people say I think I
broke something in rehearsal so what's
going through your mind when you fell I
mean the second I fell I grabbed my
wrist and it felt like sharp things
inside of it and I knew instantly that I
broke it and I knew it was going to be
over and I knew I was going to
disappoint people and I don't like to
want to make I was hoping to inspire
women my age and I hope they don't get
the wrong message from this because I
had a blast I wanted to make my kids
proud I wanted to make my friends and
fans proud and she was killing it she is
Kelly let everybody down you're so
fabulous and we love you and you'll be
back
[Music]